pete heck's up tonight and for the
remainder of the week
every other network is obsessing over
yesterday's news
got it liz jamie hates trump can't get
over it and is out of step with the gop
the congresswoman from dc her time is up
bye-bye maybe that's the story the
democrats and their friends in the media
want us to be covering the shiny object
distraction is a very powerful device
and we fall for it often
what if i told you instead a far more
sinister
and dangerous effort is underway right
under our noses right now
at the pentagon something i know a
little bit about i've been in the
military for the better part of two
decades i was in the army national guard
until last month
we all saw this coming and now
it's here this is not just the woke
military stuff you've been hearing about
this is not an extremism
stand down or a social justice reading
list or even a foolish
cia recruitment video we've all seen by
now
this is worse this is way worse
this my friends is a purge
a purge of the defense department led by
a new and now powerful
radical leftist a 1619 project activist
a hardcore
social justice democrat a man who
believes
all all trump supporters are racists
and extremists and what must we do to
racists we must define them
and then we must purge them so who is
the pentagon's newly minted
mega purge man well meet bishop
garrison the new senior adviser to the
secretary of defense his portfolio is
diversity equity and inclusion
but his purview is much wider
never heard of him me neither they like
it that way
bishop garrison has been on the job at
the pentagon for four months now
hired in the wake of the events of
january 6th the ongoing and
ongoing and ultimate justification they
sent 25 000 troops to the capitol
built a wall around it and now the rest
begins
according to an official defense
department memo signed on april 9
less than a month ago by the secretary
of defense lloyd austin himself
bishop garrison is now in charge of
countering extremism
working group the group's first meeting
was april 14th
they meet weekly maybe they met today
there is work
to be done the pentagon's countering
extremism working group which is a top
defense department priority
is immediately charged with the
following get this
revising the definition of prohibited
extremist activities
creating a reporting process for vets
soldiers who have left the force
to report extremist groups so now we
have a veteran spy network
essentially and forming yet another
commission to study extremist behavior
in the military there's more
this working group will also recommend
changing the military justice system in
order to address extremism
good woke justice enhance the military's
insider threats programs to report
concerning behaviors this used to be for
say
foreign spies i've done the training but
not anymore
we have new insider threats screening
publicly available information
on new recruits with continuous vetting
to include algorithms
into social media accounts better check
your kid's phone
if you want him or her to be a staff
sergeant someday hope they didn't
tick talk about trump or call the
election rigged the recruiter
will not tolerate that and finally
they're going to update all training
especially on
gray areas such as reading following or
liking
extremist material online catch all that
they're going to redefine extremism
empower veterans to surveil each other
re-evaluate who the real insider threats
are
screen the social media of new military
recruits and
update all training materials
but the big question is who's deciding
what's extreme
well bishop garrison of course with the
secretary of defense
right behind him now bishop garrison is
a west point grad
served two overseas tours and holds two
bronze stars for his service and we
sincerely
thank him for that but what does bishop
garrison believe today
as a civilian is he really radical maybe
he's just another you know hillary
clinton or biden harris staffer which he
was
how do i put this the white house just
put the equivalent of ibrahim x
kendi the author of how to be an
anti-racist in charge of vetting the
entire u.s military
past present and future a believer that
our founding was in 1619
will now be vetting our armed services a
few of which go back to
1776. and since we're in the mood for
vetting the military let's check a few
of bishop garrison's past tweets
and there are a lot of them in july of
2019 for example
the pentagon's brand new senior advisor
sent these two tweets
support for him meaning trump a racist
is support for all his beliefs
also tweeting he's dragging a lot of bad
actors misogynist extremists and other
racists out
into the light normalizing their actions
if you support the president
you support that there is no room
for nuance with this there's no room
for nuance if you support the president
you support extremists and racists
you support all of his beliefs as we
define them
crystal clear bishop garrison said far
worse about trump for years but that's
not the point
the scary part is what he believes about
anyone who supports trump
you are racist you are an extremist the
equation
is simple for bishop garrison if you
support trump
and supporting trump makes you a racist
and extreme then in the world of bishop
garrison
trump supporters are de facto extremists
no nuance no question no quarter
you see this isn't about white supremacy
or white nationalism
those views and tattoos have been banned
in the military
for a long time if i had a white
supremacist or racist
in my infantry platoon i could and would
kick them out
i'd have the duty but i didn't have to
because it wasn't an issue i served with
black
brown and white soldiers but in all
honesty
all i ever saw was army green
that's what the army taught me and
that's how i led
my men but for bishop garrison
all he sees is red mega red
but pete this is just a study to you
know committee to study extremism
not political persuasion oh really
think again it actually gets worse
in march of this year a leaked 17-page
darpa presentation darpa is the
pentagon's research lab
marked unclassified outlined extremism
and insider threats to the dod
the document is very startling and would
be resource material for
bishop garrison it's a type of fertile
dod cultural soil
he's standing on right now not only
does this document assert that extremism
is rampant in the military
but it suggests a new form of extremism
i'd never heard of in the military
called patriot extremism the document
defines patriot extremism as
this ideology holds that the us
government has become corrupt
has overstepped its constitutional
boundaries or is no
longer capable of protecting the people
against
foreign threats wait
so thinking the us government is corrupt
has overstepped its constitutional
boundaries
and can't defeat foreign threats makes
you an extremist
those views are mainstream conservative
thinking today
those are dangerous dangerous words
or maybe that's the point we're all
radicals
may i refer you darpa say to the
declaration of independence
the document goes on to name anarchists
and racists as well and uses this
photocollage of extremist
symbols many of these symbols are racist
or anarchist but come and take it
you see that flag in the upper left
corner that's about as
common of a military phrase or tattoo or
t-shirt as you're ever going to see
on private murphy in fact i have two
t-shirts of that at my house
not including this one that was a
lighter take at the start
of covid19 don't take my toilet paper
but maybe we're missing it maybe it's
not just about january 6
not just about trump maybe despite all
the pc and woke curriculum taught to
kids these days
the us military today really is full of
extremists and racists
maybe i just missed it of course not
on april 20th of this year less than a
month ago two of america's top
generals the head of u.s strategic
command and the head of u.s space
command
testified before the senate armed
services committee
both were asked if extremism is a
problem
in their ranks i am very confident that
the number extremist
in my forces is zero so if there are any
extremists in my organization
one they hide it very well and two it's
just a matter of time until i get to
them
i would tell you right now that we have
done everything that secretary austin
has asked us to do
in terms of training and awareness but
in my organization i would say that
number is zero
throughout my career i have not seen
that so i believe it's
close to zero in my organization if not
zero
zero or close to zero and if we find
them
we'll get them not good enough who is
dispatched to quickly dispel
those foolish notions you guessed it
bishop garrison
we would be remiss if we didn't admit
to the fact that there isn't a problem
there is a problem with
extremist behavior within the military
that is to say that one extremist
is one too many the purge is coming
they see their opening they have the
power and they have their men in the
right places
they say extremism is a huge problem
their man says trump supporters are
extremists full stop
so where does that leave trump
supporters patriots and conservatives in
the military today
vetted closeted or worse
kicked out the left knows that the
military is one of the last traditional
aggressive value-based organizations in
america so they must
dismantle it as well it started under
obama
and now it's on hyperspeed these truly
are
dangerous times